firefighters spent another night
battling some of the deadliest wildfires
in California history
those fires have killed at least 17
people in Northern California more than
2000 structures are destroyed there are
at least 17 dangerous fires burning
right now in the state much of the
destruction is in the heart of
California's wine country north of San
Francisco and we're hearing new stories
this morning about the terrifying rush
to escape those flames Carter Evans is
in Santa Rosa where the fires burned a
huge area Carter good morning good
morning home after home after home just
burned beyond recognition this was
someone's living room here the fence to
their side yard entire neighborhoods
like this one were just incinerated now
crews are combing through the wreckage
as as many as 190 people have been
reported missing
but the sheriff says that may be due to
all the chaos of the evacuations the
flames were moving so fast through
neighborhoods Tuesday night firefighters
couldn't reach homes in time to save
them stunned residents watched
helplessly as these new fires burned
south east of Santa Rosa
before-and-after photos there show
suburbs turned into wastelands as his
fire progressed
Deputy Fire Chief Scott McLean says his
teams were overwhelmed how do you even
fight a fire like this you really can't
in this case honestly you can't and
we're still in it I still have a ways to
go the fire forced frantic evacuations
Sunday night as emergency calls went out
across the region almost 80 cellphone
towers were damaged or lost power making
it difficult for families to reconnect
with their missing loved ones the fire
tore through 20,000 acres in 12 hours on
Monday that's the equivalent of burning
more than an entire football field every
three seconds that distance in just a
matter of hours
is phenomenal this newly released video
shot by a sheriff's deputy when flames
first broke out Sunday night shows the
intensity of the fire from the start
once the flames swept through nothing
but charred remains were left one
winemaker in Napa County says at least
five of the region's wineries have been
destroyed or seriously damaged and
grapes are being affected by the smoke
even at wineries untouched by flames now
this is what this neighborhood looked
like before and here is what it looks
like now you can see burnt out hulks of
cars just about everywhere you look and
firefighters tell me this is significant
they say it's an indication of how fast
this fire was truly moving people did
not even have time to get in their cars
and go to safety some were running for
their lives as for the winds today
Charlie they're supposed to pick back up
again and that could bring this fire
roaring back to life Carter thanks